[Applause]
this is Tim Kimmel the supervising sound
editor on Game of Thrones not only is he
the voice behind some of the show's
whites and White Walkers but through a
process of mixing and layering he helped
create the stuff of nightmares for the
people of Westeros and viewers at home
[Music]
warning spoilers are coming Kimmel has
been working on the show since the start
of season 3 in fact he wanted Emmy for
his work in the episode hardhome he and
the sound team had to bend a few rules
to get them to make the sound in the
first place for example creatures like
this with no skin and likely no vocal
cords probably shouldn't be able to make
any sound at all if it comes out you
quietly it doesn't really have the same
impact especially some of these
straight-up skeleton so you don't have
vocal chords so you know we sometimes
would try to lean away from the front of
whites that were so rotted away with no
flesh we talked about the sounds that
they'd be making they'd have vocal cords
that are kind of shredded the sounds
they did give them came from a variety
of places and Kimmel has an especially
personal connection with the whites some
of the sounds the whites made actually
came directly from him the sound as he
describes it came from the back of his
throat after enough distorting in the
editing room it sounds more like this
you could also hear him doing the sound
of one one the giant you know I'll admit
I'm a big metalhead I grew up in the
eighties so it is sort of a metal yell
it's a and with the white giant they
used the same sound elements but with a
grittier feel to it but it's not just
camels voice in there if you listen
carefully you might hear some animal
sounds some of the most vicious sounds
coming from the whites were actually
sounds of dogs that were manipulated and
tweaked enough that you couldn't tell
they were dog sounds originally and that
white that Jon Snow smuggled into King's
Landing to show Cersei in season seven
was actually making the sounds of a bear
cub a lot of work happens in
post-production to make sure this will
sound like this or on this scene in a
bit after years of work many sounds are
saved in a vast digital library and
reused
however the sounds they used and the
sounds the creatures make would still
change depending on the scene but has to
do with what they look like what they're
doing as they're just walking or slowly
attacking they don't make much sounds
but as they start to really attack you
know the more aggressive ones you know
will go with a more aggressive sound a
lot of it has to be story driven you
know if there's one that's right on top
of a main character that you're worried
is gonna kill them we'll find the most
aggressive one we can find it really
make the viewer worry oh no this is it
helps I'm call that story a little bit
more the more aggressive the creatures
the more aggressive the sounds they use
will get you can't talk about the sounds
of the whites and white walkers without
discussing how they move much of the
movements are done through fully a
process in which real objects are used
to create sounds of living creatures
interacting with the world when it comes
to their movement they start bare bones
literally as a lot of the whites are
nothing but skeletons they used real
bones and ceramic objects but you'll
also hear a lot of
their sounds at play in any given scenes
where the undead army is scurrying
around you know a lot of those whites
were soldiers and they have some armor
still hanging off of them or some
leather hanging out for them so we also
incorporate that incorporate some kind
some of the flesh sounds a little bit a
little bit of cloth just so it's not
just bones just it it gives a little
more depth the further the show has
moved along the more White's they've had
to deal with when Kimmel first started
working on the show they were making
sound for just a handful of them on the
other hand the Battle of Winterfell saw
the north faced off against an army of
thousands of lights and White Walkers
during this battle they were dealing
with hundreds of different sounds at
once one of the biggest challenges was
capturing sound that really gave the
audience the feel of the scope of this
army as the North's army waited for the
undead to approach it had to be very
quiet at first and then get
progressively louder as they crept
closer and closer to the city's walls
you have to get as big as you can for
that first wave so it just feels huge
but what was tricky in the shot was that
first wave hits and then you get to a
reaction shot of the other part of the
army and then there's a second wave that
comes in so if you go too big on the
first wave you don't feel the second way
so you had to find a way to feel big but
still have room to get even bigger but
surprisingly the hardest moments for
Kimmel and his team came not when
dealing with armies but when dealing
with a single white on screen back to
that scene where Jon brings a white into
King's Landing usually want these whites
are going there's a lot of stuff to hide
behind there's other battle things and
so it's not as how the open so you can
kind of do more with it and get away
with little cheats but this thing was on
its own and needs to be scary
[Applause]
the thing that made the whites and white
walkers truly terrifying throughout
their run wasn't just the sounds they
made but also the ones they didn't make
and in early appearance in season two
you can hear a white Walker speak in
scruff their native tongue this was then
abandoned in later appearances Kimmel
also pointed out that in early
appearances the night King would open
his mouth and show his teeth they just
found him more intimidating to just be
there with a straight look on his face
he's just standing there confident you
know you don't know what what he's gonna
do or what he's capable of
sometimes no sound is the scariest sound
of all